un vaccin efficace à 90% contre le coc
vide 19 c'est ce qu'annonce l'américain
pfizer et son partenaire allemand bio
ntech dans un communiqué conjoint
diffusé ce lundi
aujourd'hui est un grand jour pour la
science et l'humanité le premier
ensemble des résultats de notre essai de
vaccin covit 10,9 de phase iii fourni la
preuve initial de la capacité de notre
vaccin à prévenir locaux vides 19
la première analyse intermédiaire de la
phase 3 de notre étude mondiale fournit
la preuve qu'un vaccin peut prévenir
efficacement le coc vite 19
c'est une victoire pour l'innovation la
science est un effort collaboratif
mondiale
cette fameuse phase iii a débuté le 27
juillet dernier 40 3538 personnes y ont
participé
sur ces individus un groupe a reçu le
vrai vaccins l'autre s'est vu inoculer
un placebo pour mesurer ce taux
d'efficacité à 90% les deux laboratoires
ont comparé le nombre de participants
infectés par le cos vie de 19 dans les
deux groupes
ils en ont donc conclu que les personnes
ayant reçu le vrai vaccins ont 90 % de
risques en moins d'être contaminés une
bonne nouvelle donc mais qu'il faut tout
de même relativiser premièrement le
vaccin des deux laboratoires se base sur
une technologie appelée arn messenger
totalement nouvelle celle ci n'a à ce
jour pas encore fait ses preuves
deuxièmement les essais cliniques sont
toujours en cours et les résultats n'ont
été publiés dans aucune revue
scientifique comme l'indiquent ce
virologue chez nos confrères de marielle
ces résultats sont donnés par le biais
d'un communiqué de presse et nous via un
rapport scientifique il est difficile de
tirer des conclusions
nous manquons par exemple cruellement
d'informations sur ce qu'ils entendent
par protection cela concerne-t-il tous
les types de malade qu'aggraver cap
léger quelle tranche d'âge sont
concernées par cette protection
comment l'immunité évolue-t-elle dans le
temps les personnes immunisées
sont-elles vectrices du virus beaucoup
de questions restent en suspens si bon
nombre d'organisations salue ces
nouvelles encourageantes la prudence est
tout de même de mise au sein de la
communauté scientifique
exemple avec ce tweet vaccin files
heures les questions en suspens confirmé
les premiers résultats
combien de temps dure l'immunité quels
sont les effets secondaires
les formes sévères sont elles aussi
éviter les plus fragiles sont il est
immunisée on reste prudent même si
l'espoir est là malgré tout de nombreux
pays ont déjà conclu des accords avec
les deux laboratoires ou sont en passe
de le faire
c'est le cas des etats-unis du canada du
japon ou encore de l'union européenne la
france elle fait savoir par la voix du
porte parole du gouvernement qu'il est
trop tôt pour décider des conditions de
déploiement du vaccin dans le pays de
leur côté files heures et bio ntech ont
pour objectif de fournir jusqu'à 100
millions de doses dans le monde d'ici à
la fin de l'année et 1,3 milliard de
plus en 2021